welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul and this video we're
breaking down the falcon and winter
soldier trailer to point out the best
easter eggs in it
just a bit of housekeeping before we
begin you may have watched our loki
trailer breakdown yesterday and
we said that the seated figure in it
could be black widow
however many of you reached out to the
show and said that this is in fact
lady loki and after checking out the
behind the scenes leaked images of the
character
i definitely think it's now her she will
be played by sophie di martino
so it doesn't look like we'll be seeing
scholar johansson
in an alternate reality for now now
there was also a devastated new york
and shout outs to bok bok tube for
coming up with the best theory
which is that this is caused by the nuke
that was fired in the avengers
it is very likely that in an alternate
reality tony failed to stop it
and due to the massive crater in the
middle i think that makes the most sense
anyway under the falcon and winter
soldier trailer and though it initially
seems to play things pretty close to the
chest
when you dive deep into it there is a
lot to uncover the trailer begins at the
smithsonian institution
captain america exhibit we last saw this
in the winter soldier
but since then cap has obviously gone
through a lot
there was not only civil war but also
infinity war and of course
end game in which the character
disappeared to live out the life he
should have had with peggy carter
the layout of the exhibit has been
changed quite a lot
and at the center of it is captain
america's shield at the close of end
game
steve of course gave it to sam but it
looks like he either had to hand it over
or the government took it from him
throughout the trailer we see him at
several points fighting against the
forces of evil
so we know that for the meantime he
doesn't have it on him
we also see a government appointed
captain america aka us agent
played by wyatt russell and he has it
instead so it seems like
sam probably had to hand it over in
order to keep the peace
the world currently believes that
captain america died during the final
battle of
endgame and thus he can't really tell
people that he actually inherited the
item from an old steve rogers
so for the meantime it must remain here
now we did see him practicing at his
home in new orleans in the first teaser
but he likely handed it back because of
all the issues that it could cause
sam stares at the shield through its
glass case and the character
is slightly off-center from it we saw
something similar
into the spider-verse with miles and
here it clearly symbolizes that the two
are not fully lined up
sam says the legacy of that shield is
complicated
and we pull out to see bucky listening
intently now there are reports that asia
bradley
aka the first black captain america will
be revealed
and we'll discover that the us
government actually carried out
experiments on black soldiers during the
war
the show could tackle issues like race
and potentially dive into how after they
perfected the serum
they instead gave it to steve who was
white and therefore
appealed more to the public shows like
lovecraft
country and watchmen 2 tackled similar
aesthetics
and with some of the backlash that
endgame received due to making the next
captain america black
i think it would be the perfect topic to
talk about go to the marvel studios logo
and this one is rather simple in the
case of loki
there was a lot going on but here it
just seems like a cool color technique
without too much double meaning
now from here we cut to a convoy that
looks very similar to the one that we
saw in the trailer for black widow
it is possible that general ross could
be in this or
someone else attached to the us
government during the events of infinity
war
we know that ross wasn't too happy with
steve and this is likely why they
decided to appoint their own captain
america
rather than someone else jump to
madrapur aka the fictional asian country
from the marvel universe inspired by
singapore
this location was leaked when flags were
spotted on set for the series
and it looks like the pair will be
investigating crime in the area
what's interesting about madrapore is
that there's a dichotomy to it
and the city actually has two sections
this includes high town
and lowtown both of which are as bad as
each other
hightown is a corrupt white-collar
crime-esque area
that the elites reside in and they use
their power to control lowtown through
their network of criminal organizations
now the duality of this is also
reflected in both sam and bucky
the pair have their own aspects and are
not held in high regards
but as we know things aren't as they
seem thus
this feels like the perfect mission for
them to take part in and i can actually
see them splitting up and going through
the city from top to bottom we then
catch a german police force
running through corridors if you cast
your mind back to civil war
you'll remember that bucky bust up a lot
of police heads in the country
so it could be that they're on high
alert now he's returned to the location
however they could also be scrambling
because of our next scene
which shows gasoline kick starting an
explosion
likely led by the next character that is
a flag smasher
now in the comics flag smasher is a man
that's basically the opposite
of captain america around here we call a
flag smasher
someone that air loves their country and
bangs on about it
all day on twitter however in the comics
flag smasher hates what captain america
represents
and they want to tear down the
government as well as its ideals
the design looks very similar to the mcu
crossbones
so who knows the two may be linked in
some way we can also hear bucky say the
world is upside down
and it seems that in the five years that
everyone got dusted
organizations like this have been able
to rise and cause chaos
people returning from the blip may also
have found their lives torn apart
as jobs they once had have probably been
filled
and their homes could have been taken
over by others thus
bringing everyone back will have caused
some issues and people
may have turned to crime in order to get
by cut to louisiana
and this appears to be sam's home from
the first trailer
anthony mackie is actually from new
orleans so it looks like they could be
returning to his roots
we also catch bucky on a trawler before
we cut to sam unpacking what may be his
wings from a briefcase
in iron man 2 tony kept one of his suits
in one which was called the football
so this motif has likely carried on here
there's also a sign that says
wilson family seafood so we can guess
that's how his family made their money
now this boat could be what's used to
enter madrapore though we don't know for
definite
bucky says people need something to get
behind and after the fall of captain
america
it's likely that the people of the us
have lost hope
this explains why the government
appointed u.s agent and
just wanted to fill the void that was
left behind in his absence
the people of earth have been through a
lot and they're likely scared of
something like this snap happening again
so they're going to be looking for
symbols of strength to gravitate towards
we also see the new falcon costume which
looked more in line with something from
the comics
there's clearly been some upgrades and i
doubt sam could have made this himself
so perhaps in handing over the shield
the government gave him something in
return
we then cut to several action shots
before settling on zemo at a sokovia
memorial
we know that daniel bruhl will be coming
back as the character
and though he was arrested at the end of
civil war it seems like he got out
the death of all those close to him is
what caused the character to tear the
avengers apart
and this is a nice shot which is
followed up by bucky unloading bullets
in front of him
i actually have a theory that bucky went
to him and zemo tried to get him to end
his life
by saying the words that controlled the
character as we know
zemo attempted to take his own life at
the end of civil war
so potentially he's trying to do it
again here but this time through bucky
however bucky unloading the bullets show
that zemo no longer has control over him
and he's likely now a free man mentally
now if you're enjoying the video
i'm gonna use my mind control powers to
make you click the thumbs up button
probably didn't work but if you're
enjoying it i'd love it if you
subscribed as well
as we're giving away three copies of the
lord of the rings 4k box set to people
who are part of the channel
and we'll talk about that more in the
video as we get into it anyway
we then jump to the us agent parade and
can see that the government have chosen
john walker to be the character
walker was a sort of deranged captain
america
and he took being a patriot too far
often killing people that questioned the
government
or opposed things like vietnam he was
chosen over sam because the commission
on superhuman affairs
didn't think the public was ready for a
black captain america
and this ties back to why sam may have
had to hand over the shield
we then go back to madrapa namely a
nightclub
and sam can be seen flying under a truck
showing just how skilled he is as a
pilot
later he fights flag smasher on top of
this so it seems like the organization
is trying to hijack it
they escape in a helicopter and falcon
can also be seen fighting the character
in what looks like it could be sokovia
if you look closely on the truck you can
also see what looks to be us
agent so he probably showed up to help
sam beat the bad guys
and then likely took the credit for
himself in the comics
u.s agent actually worked with
organizations like smashers to carry out
attacks
and he then stepped in and stopped them
in order to boost his public image
that could be what's going on here but
obviously we'll not know until the show
releases
now kurt debucky on a bike in what is
likely madrid and we can see
that he has a way of keeping up with sam
at the very least
you can also see that his arm has a
flame symbol on it which
okay boomer i guess that looks cool a
couple of action shots here and there
and we then get bucky doing his knife
tricks that were seen in the winter
soldier
i love this moment as you may remember
that in the first avenger
howard said hydra wouldn't be coming at
them with pocket knives
however bucky actually did when he and
steve faced off later down the line
the pair can also be seen running
through madrapura likely after being
caught
cut to them on a plane with bucky asking
what the plan is
sam then dives out of it without a
parachute similar to how steve did in
the winter soldier
he's chased through what i think is the
grand canyon and
don't hate me i forgot that wrong
america and an attack chopper fires on
him
completely decimating the landscape it's
a cool aerial action shot
letting us know that just because this
is a tv show
it doesn't mean you won't have the high
quality combat that we expect from the
marvel universe
and all in all it's a brilliant way to
take us to the title
we see sam's wings and bucky's arms
which now have gold in them
suggesting that he may have had some
upgrades the teaser ends with sam
mockingbucky for being a
brain-controlled assassin
and bucky says gotta hate you now this
is a callback to civil war
in which sam said the same thing to him
so it's nice that the boys
still have a bit of banter with each
other lads lads
anyway that wraps it up and of course
let me know if you spotted something
that i didn't
because even the spoiler man you know
the spoiler man misses stuff too
now don't forget that on the 30th of
december we're giving away three copies
of the lord of the rings 4k box set
to our subscribers all you have to do to
be with the chance of winning is like
the video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the trailer if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of the loki
teaser which will be linked at the end
i think there's some really cool little
easter eggs in it and
it should be linked on screen right now
so what the heck ins are you waiting for
anyway without the way thank you for
sitting through the video me
me and you we're just like uh the winter
soldier and bucky artwork as we're best
mate
and that means i'll see you next time
take care peace
another terrible outro but you have a
good weekend yeah take